[MUSIC PLAYING]
ANNE HOLTON: I learned
crucial lessons
of humility and appreciation
of differential human talent.
I also learned
that sometimes it's
OK to try something so
hard that success is not
a foregone conclusion.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
BAZ LUHRMANN:
Listen to everyone.
Listen to your friends.
Listen to your enemies.
But then, go into a
corner and ask yourself,
not, 'what do I think?' but,
'what do I actually feel?
What do I feel?'
And that decision, my friends,
will be the right decision.
Because you made it.
And it wasn't made for you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
SANJEEV KULKARNI: This
educational process
at Princeton cultivates in
you the ability and confidence
to succeed and lead in new
areas of inquiry, in new fields,
and in new endeavors
throughout your lives.
Congratulations on
your accomplishments.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
JIN YUN CHOW: More
often than not,
it's not because of some
orchestrated, pre-planned
effort that we end up sharing
a beautiful bond of friendship
with someone.
It's because we were
present to talk.
there to listen.
Here's to all of our
heroes, known and unknown,
sung and unsung, who got us
through these four years.
To them and to everyone
who has been there for us
through this journey, thank you.
CHRISTOPHER L. EISGRUBER: The
place of learning, he said,
should be a large and lasting
one consistent in character
and scale with the values of
this university from which you
are now to take your lead.
May it be a place able to
accommodate the fun of learning
as well as the effort that
all true learning requires.
May its boundaries
be set not by what
we think we know now but
by a lifelong curiosity
and an abiding
appreciation for ideas,
for their elusiveness
to be sure,
but also for their power, their
beauty, and their capacity
to enrich our lives and
the lives of others.
To all of you who received
degrees from this university,
from all of us here
on the platform,
congratulations to the
great Class of 2017.
Onward!
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]